with csb at checking in live and check
me out on the bootleg Kev podcast
show a special guest here
Bea Superstar welcome
thanks for having me
um I just want to start the interview
off
because we just had this
um
hypothetical situation where I was
asking my boy his Millis came in and he
has a pretty strong Boston accent for
the most part right
and
can you kind of like break down to me
like well one you don't have like a
crazy Boston accent and
but like do you have friends that are
like women that have a hard time like
finding good men because they sound like
like oh yeah [__] Tom [__] Brady
they smoke cigarettes like I just I just
feel like if I grew up in Boston
and a girl talk like you know Millies
are like slain you know I'd be Judy yeah
like oh my God come here honey go get
the [__] calm a little [__] drunk
over here like I just feel like it'd be
like a turn off so like you have friends
that run into that I don't have any
friends that talk like that but it's
just like some of my friends moms okay
or like God bless their husbands maybe
even sometimes my mom sounds like that
sometimes it's like an older
like I feel like you know white busted
woman thing yeah it's like the car the
bar the star yeah it's like fine let's
go five talk like that yeah yeah like
that [__] Tom Brady I love him he's a
buck but I [__] love him still I love
it it's his own thing yeah for sure do
you still do you find yourself still
rooting for Tom well he's retired now
but were you rooting for Tom when he was
over in Tampa Bay
um I wouldn't say like
I wouldn't say like rooting for him but
um like I definitely think he has like a
warm place in every Bostonian or
Massachusetts person's heart yes it
should yeah because all he's done for
the Patriots I think about that scene in
Ted 2 where Ted like sneaks into his
house to steal his comments yes and I
was like yeah I'm sure a lot of people
in Boston would have done so weird
great movie by the great Boston yeah Ted
is an amazing movie they're they're
doing a TV show have you heard no I
didn't hear that they're like all series
no way yeah it should be good I hope I
could be in it shout out to Ted like
calling me well I want to say congrats
because you're like turned into like a
Bonafide Superstar oh thank you so much
and you have like a really long journey
in this music industry you've been
through deals where you know certain
people didn't get it and you've just
kind of just transformed into like uh
one of the you know artists on The
Forefront of this Rapture so
congratulations I appreciate you a lot
thank you
um have you noticed like besides you
know obviously you're doing a lot of
shows you're doing a lot of festivals I
see you doing clubs you're in Vegas you
got you have Vegas residency right now
yeah I have um I have one with Grace
right now uh before dress we did Jewel
and hakkasan so Tau group nah but like
have you noticed like for you was there
anything that changed
in terms of like where you started to
kind of see like things finally really
like work out in a big way
like where in terms of like were you
like doing anything differently or was
it just like finally the kind of the
Stars like aligned you know I think it's
a little bit of both I think uh when
every every time you see like an artist
have a moment I think there's like a
wonderful team behind the scenes like
that's helping them be great and I also
think that the stars are aligning
um and what I've learned through those
moments is just to like be way more
confident with whatever it is I'm doing
and just be sure of it before I press go
because then it's like it's foolproof
for sure do you because I feel like
there was like a moment where
you had gotten off of RCA because you
were on RCA for a while yeah like four
and a half years maybe
um and then the rust record happened yes
and then I feel like after that it was
just over after that has been kind of
busy because we well actually it was
crazy because the best on Earth happened
and then the pandemic hit so we weren't
really like able to work
um best on earth like in the clubs when
it first came out we didn't even end up
performing it together until a year
later right so uh that changes things I
think as well
um there's a lot of songs that I think
would have hit like in a different way
had we been able to be outside and has
had the stars and learned at that time
but either way I'm super grateful for
how it all turned out because I'm just
like
so blown away like you your plans are
never going to be as good as God's plans
for real yeah I think like I was just
like thinking like damn you got a record
with Nikki and a record with J Cole like
two of the greatest of all time crazy
right yeah like do you ever like look
back and just think like Dan the last
two and a half years have been like
kind of surreal like I gotta kind of do
you appreciate it yes absolutely oh my
goodness like everybody that knows me
knows like I'm heavy on prayer like I
talked to God like a million times a day
and I'm just super grateful like I'm one
of those people that I I've seen so many
moments like come and go for me so now
I'm learning to just be like way more
present in those moments and appreciate
them for what they are and not like I
seek no expectations when I put music
out I just be like all right I'm gonna
put this out and whatever happens
happens and it's always some amazing
stuff that happens and so I'm always
like
shocks me right tell me the story on how
uh because you've told it before but
like the London record is one of my
favorite joints you put out you did a
great job on that record thank you yeah
it was I [__] played the [__] out of
that on the radio
um but how does Cole end up on that
particular song where you're doing the
whole London thing it's crazy because uh
we went to the studio to go meet Cole
for a whole completely different song
and um before we were on our way out I
was like hey can I play you something
like I'm you know I'm working on my
project I want to play this song and
he's like yeah go ahead I press play and
he loved the song He's like I love this
song this is good like
um
I was like okay you know what that's
like he just seemed like he really liked
the song and I wanted to send it to him
like some random day so like two weeks
later I think a month later I said it to
him and I was like hey just sending you
this if you want to listen to it if you
want to check it out since you said you
liked it you listen to it and you're on
your bike ride at the gym like whatever
you want and um yeah it just ended up
working out like that like he ended up
liking the song enough that he wanted to
put a verse on it and I was so happy
about that because
like look at that verse it's like one of
my favorite verses of all time oh he
killed it he got off how could I just
seen this one or that one I could have
both oh my God he got oh he did not give
you the throwaway covers I know he has
those by the way I feel like every time
he gets on some [__] he bodies it he
does and I honestly wanted to I was like
yo I'm gonna go because when I first cut
the record London it was like a vibey
fun record like me and Aziz we just have
fun like if you know us we go to the
studio and we just try to have a good
time so we weren't over we don't really
try to overthink anything or try to make
a a hit or try to make a certain type of
record we just catch a Vibe so I wasn't
overthinking or like pushing my pen to
the to the bars like expecting to get J
Cole on that song So when he put his
verse on it I'm like I'm gonna go redo
my verse they're like he's like no no no
they wouldn't they told me not to they
were not supposed to do it yeah that's
kind of like uh cheating but like yeah I
was like bro like who who thinks when
they cut like a random reference that
Cole's gonna be on that song yeah it's
crazy I think that's against like unsaid
rappers too like if you send a record in
with your verse and then it comes out
and your verse is way different
it's fine I think that I think that
might have been the root of the whole
like cannabis LL thing back but I didn't
do it because I didn't want to change
the the essence and the energy because
you know sometimes they got that a
certain like energy to them did like
anybody in London like feel like you
were appropriating their accent
I mean nobody said that to me but I just
wonder because everyone's so sensitive
these days and like you know I was shout
out to England the colonizers of all
colonized machine but
um I just wonder if they had like you
know yo what like you're taking our you
know I mean I got so much love in London
such a great record like I love London
so much and it became like my second
like I want to see like my second or
third home because I was traveling to
London so often around that time so when
we when it came time that I did London I
was just so inspired by the culture yeah
so I was just like how can I put this
culture in a song without trying to like
piss anybody off but still make it my
own you've worked with Pharrell
and you have the new record where you're
working with Timberland and shout out to
Timberland in my opinion he's he's my
personal
he's not my favorite but he's Timmy the
goat because I think his range is so
crazy but uh what was it like what's the
difference between working with Pharrell
and Timberland who are on the Mount
Rushmore of the producer game you know
um they're completely different people
they're completely they have completely
different like Styles and approaches I'd
say like I mean
they both the one thing I do say is like
similar when it comes to like great
great producers is there very much like
into the vibe like whatever there's like
an energy you know what I'm saying the
vibe has to be good for like the vibe
has to be right so
um there I'm just so grateful that I've
worked with both of them because they're
so different
I can't say like really what
what about the process are you like
either of those guys have you cooked up
from scratch with them are they just
playing you like a folder yes we cooked
it from scratch
um many times yeah no nice well that
weekend that I worked with Timberland it
was the week in art basil we cooked it
from scratch and then there's been many
times I've cooked up from scratch
overall nice
how was our basil our person was Vibes I
like our puzzle I
about it but I appreciate it
yeah I guess that's fair I feel like I'm
the same way I appreciate it I'm buying
it but I appreciate it I'll buy like a
you know a print of it yeah you know no
I won't I'll buy like that like that's
art like a dude redid the Wrestlemania
13 poster so I bought it you know and I
appreciated it or like if there's a what
about if there's an artist that you that
you're like oh I like your workout so
I'll buy and support and like grab a
piece sure if I know the artist yeah I
don't know any of those people yet
um so all the artists need to hit you up
on Instagram and show you that works
like it though it's got to be fly you
know it's got to be like there's some
good art oh for sure some of the [__] I
don't get though it's my eyes you know
to each or something like the plate
spatter is not your stuff no I don't get
it so when you go to Miami for our
basketball you end up at any strip clubs
at all like do you do a level while
you're out there I love 11. I um
yeah I love 11. like they're like really
good friends
I feel like you've been you've been
booked there before right yeah I've been
booked at 11 quite a few times I love 11
so much it's like my happy place I think
it is quite possibly the best club in
the world it's like top five top three
top two maybe one I'd say that because
it's like you get the best of it's like
a Vegas club with chicks exactly and
it's 24 hours yeah like you gotta be
like a mani I'm a maniac what's the
latest or the earliest in the morning
you've walked out of a club
the next day like 2 P.M
Jesus yeah 11.
how many hours wait wait how many hours
were you there
probably like 10
11 hours
what are you doing inside of 11 for that
long is there I mean are you eating are
you I mean obviously throwing money or
drinking Raging Raging yeah raging of
course that's a lot dancing raging
drinking dancing I've walked out of the
booby trap at around nine a.m yeah but
that's like to me that's manageable in
Miami like 2 p.m that's a lot that's
like super degenerative I think we went
there at like 8 A.M okay that's fair so
like 7 A.M I don't know if you were like
yo I performed at 2 30 and I stayed
until two no no no I pulled a whole
12-hour shift in that [__] no no no I
didn't performance day it was like we
were outside and then we went to 11 for
breakfast ah
they got breakfast like omelets yeah
they got like these Chicken and Waffles
that's fire chicken and waffles in the
morning if you go in the morning because
they're 24 hours so we had been out all
night and then we went to 11 and I think
we left at like 2 p.m
um
is it nice to have the barbs in your
corner
I feel like the barbs [__] with you and
that's a good place to be in and just in
the world yeah they've shown me so much
love and so much support like The Vibes
are like
like who needs a
like for Nikki it's like she doesn't
even need a label like she she are their
own Army like she just treated last
night because she didn't go to met Galen
she was like number one on trending
Legend
it's crazy because the barbs came to my
defense because I said something about
uh I love Little Kim but I said
something that little Kim's whatever
they're called they're her barbs and
they came at me crazy for like two days
and then the barbs had my back they're
crazy it's just like a real army what is
do you have a fan base name
it's crazy
um I've titled and title with a couple
names but I think I'm gonna probably
just find one that comes naturally like
yeah yeah have you seen swarm on uh
Amazon Prime yet yes I did it's really
really crazy and it's also kind of like
scary like that it's kind of like not
too far from reality like and it's it's
a little crazy because
you don't really see women serial
killers so that was there was that one
movie uh
uh monster with Charlize Theron did you
ever watch that she was a serial killer
she was like a prostitute she used to
kill Truckers
yeah it was a good movie I'm gonna I
know Charlize Theron she's like really
beautiful girls yeah she like took on a
role as like this like white trash like
trucker lady who was like a lot lizard
do you know what a lot lizard is I don't
know what a lot lizard is
so it was a lot lizard
if you're a truck driver
they have truck stops and it's girls who
offer lonely men who are in trucks at
truck stops in the middle of nowhere
certain services so why they call them
lizards that's just what they call them
they call them a lot lizard that is
gross it is gross well it's a dirty name
like I I don't I don't disagree it's a
dirty name for a dirty job
um yo on this record uh you dropped 16
which I think is dope because you're
getting your [__] off on that oh thanks
give me some yo what so what job did you
get fired from
oh man I had like a a job at a like when
I was I had tons of jobs I had every
single job like grocery store bartending
waitressing but it was like a bartending
job
I didn't oh yeah it was a bartending job
and you just told me to go [__] them and
Foot Locker too Footlocker yeah but I
had I have a great relationship with
Footlocker like I I was like employee of
the year really no no no not really but
could could you like were you like top
tier assistant are you back door in any
of the shoes no I had keys and
everything I was super responsible like
good employee I was that girl yeah so
you weren't like if the pair of Jordans
came out no I wasn't stealing no no I'm
not saying stealing but you might set up
a parasite for you for the homie like
you know yeah I did that a few times
yeah uh yeah I used to do that for my
friends what was the last real job you
had was it the bartending thing yeah
and you just like did you literally tell
them [__] you when you when you got
fired
no I didn't actually not that one
um one of them yeah but not not the last
one so you could make a drink like you
could make like a yeah I'm actually like
I can make it I'm a really a chef
what can you cook everything literally
everything when you say you're really a
chef what does that mean like the same
do you have like a certificate that says
so
are you just I'm a hood Chef you're a
hood Chef okay yes so what's like the
go-to if I had to be like okay Shelby
like what is your what are you gonna
make there you're very confident in
um well what do you like I'm I'm into
everything
I'm a fat [__] as we discussed like I
got some famous dishes of mine like if
you had to cook a dish for uh
give me the Gordon Ramsay dish he's
sitting there all right like I'm a
cookie so I would make an I would make a
medley of things okay because I I feel
as though if I have a medley I can't
lose if you don't like one thing he's
gonna like another thing so I would do
like these um lamb chops that I do these
garlic Char mint lamb chops the mint
okay they very like taste level like
very high like it's not even regular at
all and then I would do a Chilean sea
bass
oh and then
I would do uh on another day if you come
I would do coconut curry chicken and
white rice Jesus that's a famous meal of
mine the people go crazy for you see
he's not in his head people go crazy the
people go absolutely insane and last but
not least lasagna rolls talk about it
that sounds fire
yo the best Italian food I ever had was
in Boston in Little Italy and there's
like those little bakeries that stay
open all night yeah oh my God cannolis
oh my goodness I miss the cannoli every
guy at the [__] club from DJ and [__]
face and there was a [__] Bakery open
at three in the morning like what the
[__] is going on over here
I love a bakery so lasagna rolls yo
what's good man we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our good
Folks at my bookie that's right man NBA
season is uh winding down playoffs are
going down so many ways you can get
money you could bet on who you think is
going to finals you can get your prop
bets per game uh we are finally down to
the final eight right now uh my son's
ain't looking good at the time of
recording not looking good uh look go to
mybookie.ag right now sign up
I've been gambling on my bookie for over
10 years so listen come and join me
let's get this money together
mybookie.ag when you use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up use that promo
code you're gonna get that deposit bonus
that deposit bonus is craziest the sign
up bonus you get and not only are
basketball football which is starting to
creep up on us baseball's back MLB
baseball man all season long you get
this money plus they got the online
casino if you're into craps Blackjack
roulette [__] slot machines whatever
it is go to mybookie.ag right now use
that promo code bootleg and get that
free deposit bonus that's how we're
doing things all right also I want to
give a big shout out to the homies of
King Palm man these are our new sponsors
at King Palm now this is the thing about
these King Palms man these things right
here
ah natural natural leaves free of
tobacco and additives the only thing I
smoke out of and what's dope is they got
these other ones right these uh this is
one of their more popular items right
here
great flavor
these are the leaf rolls they hold a
gram each and they got the terpene fused
tips which means you squeeze and you pop
the tip while you're smoking your flour
and you get a little burst of flavor
these are the peach pineapples
um they got the energy drink flavor they
got blue blueberry watermelon all kinds
of [__] man
um so what's dope if you go to
kingpom.com and use the promo code
bootleg Kev right now you're gonna get
half off half off
half off kingpom.com tobacco free
natural
wraps all right and also don't forget if
you're in a I don't know wherever you're
at go to 7-Eleven they got them your
local smoke shop one of the most
successful uh businesses in the game
when it comes to the all-natural Leaf
the most successful no tobacco no
nicotine just natural Leafs to stuff
your flour in and in case you did not
know they also have
whatever size King Palm this is this is
a giant Leaf wrapped around yeah wrapped
around some premium can I buy shout out
to uh King pump go follow one more time
kingpound.com promo code bootleg Kev say
50 off let's get back to the interview
would you ever okay because right now
you know there's this like all these
rappers are doing like an artist like uh
Mr Beast all these guys they're doing
like uh ghost kitchens right yes so you
could do like BS bites oh you come on
with the ideas and then you could just
license it to a ghost kitchen and come
up with their own menu and then give
them the recipes and then you know
people all over the world can just but
they will have then they'll have my
recipes
I mean it could be like a watered-down
version of the recipe like I feel like a
lasagna roll would be like like let me
get six of those like in a little box
yeah it's like that yeah yeah
you should do that you know what next
time I come I might bring a lasagna rose
that would be amazing yeah next time I
come here I'll bring lasagna Rose I'll
break my diet for that okay I'm on a
keto diet
just because I like to brag about how
good it is and then people then you can
then you can vouch for me so I don't
have to do the talking next time you'd
be like you know who's a really good
Chef yeah
um how's the album coming along it's
actually like uh mixing mastering
finished so it's done like you're not
turning anything new in yeah no no when
you do like well I can't say that
because if if when verses come through
last minute yeah if you get a crazy
verse at the end of the Finish Line I'm
gonna put it on in terms of your parts
my part is done my part is done when you
like put out no my part is never all the
way done I might seek inspiration
tomorrow and just add one in there for a
um surprise so Wednesday I'm dropping
you're here so you're obviously working
I mean oh yeah it's it's so it's pretty
much sealed up do you have you let the
name fly yet no but I'm it's I'm so
happy about the name are you I can't
tell you yet but
is the artwork done yes oh yes
for you like do you feel like because
you've put out some big singles
when you drop the album and you have
like a song like London or besito with a
with G herbo are those like bonus tracks
are you working those into the track
listing of the album
um those
I think yeah put them at the end so they
count towards the whole thing dude you
got to pull the French Montana it
depends that what besito was not on this
album
so it's not going to be on like at the
end as a no but Sita was on was it on
yeah oh it was on the deluxe okay yeah
so London will be on
on maybe
well yeah for sure it will be on this
one yeah it is yeah you got to put it on
there no it is London will be on this
one but that's probably like the only
record in um well London and I'm that
[__] is there um
any features you can reveal
no none only because like I just like
surprises some surprises yeah like I
like to just like
let it let it come out how big of a
surprise
I like big surprises you know me like a
stadium surprise or like a House of
Blues across I like a big surprise okay
I like a little Razzle Dazzle every now
and then any Boston features not on this
one but me and Millie's will definitely
do a song we've been trying to find the
time his schedule and my schedule is
like crazy
Millie's is uh he's having a moment
right now he's incredible like I'm so
happy for him I met him in uh South by
Southwest in like 2013 at the hotel
lobby he came up to me and was like I
watch your [__] on two dope boys and now
right now that's what's up I didn't
again a long journey yeah I'm so happy
to see like everybody like around the
world really catch on him too because
he's really so genuine and just so good
at what he does
it's like
people need to know about him who would
you put on the Boston hip or let's just
say Massachusetts because we if Joyner
Lucas is not from Boston who's on the
Mount Rushmore of of if you had to
exclude yourself because you're up there
but
[Music]
um
Massachusetts as a state Massachusetts
yes I would go like Legends too like
I'll put Guru of course I would do like
uh a lot of people don't know gurus from
Boston and Primos from Texas
um
that's a hard one man uh that's a tough
one
would you let Benzino sniff it just take
a sniff sniff what the Mount Rushmore of
Boston or Massachusetts hip-hop would
you let him at least
would you at least like invite him to
the you gotta
got it crazy
sniff it is crazy I mean like would you
let him sniff the list would you like
consider him
I mean the source was big you know made
man yeah of course yo The Source in
itself the almighty RSO you know yeah no
like for sure like yeah Benzino
he's definitely important to the culture
he's important yeah absolutely you're on
there
gurus on there
I don't I don't like this question
Joyner Lucas is on there yeah for sure
I'll let you I'll let you pick the rush
more and I'll just say give you thumbs
can we go non-rappers yeah please static
selector static selecta number
one okay
terminology terminology is up there yeah
like shout out to term man anybody I'm
forgetting
I like that I don't know it's like I'm
so
I gotta like tap more back into the
Boston scene because there's a lot of
cousin stizzes from there who was uh
Michael Christmas uh
I know way too much about what's the
what's the guy's name who's named after
beer that's oh is it Samuel Adams from
there Sammy Adams
see I never got into his voice yeah I
missed that whole [__]
but shout out to him
but you're up there yeah are we
considering koi from Boston is she from
Boston she has roots for sure yeah she's
from she's kind of like Boston in Jersey
have you and her uh got to link up and
connect and yeah we're real cool like
outside of music too yeah she's she
seems like a great energy yeah I love
her she's super genuine and like I'm
super happy for her as well how cool was
it getting on uh the Nikki remix that
just dropped because it seemed like she
you know when she chooses an all Queen
lineup of artists to hop on a remix
that's got to be a dope honor to be
included in that absolutely yeah she any
I'm I'm so just inspired by like Nikki
Rihanna so many women that I've I've had
the chance to cross paths with that
really inspire me have shown me so much
love so
it's made me in turn be like okay I want
to do that for the other women that are
like coming up the other the younger
girls is because that I've only received
that you know like it gets weird
sometimes like music industry stuff and
girls but it's really just like I feel
like
to support what you genuinely like and
then like I feel like that comes back
well I think you've done a really good
job of like uh just I don't ever see
your name like wrapped up in any of the
like unnecessary drama sometimes I feel
other artists I'm just like what's going
on why is like these people have no
reason to have problems with each other
like it just doesn't make sense so it's
good to see like you're I feel like you
you're kind of also like very mature
like you're like you're like a young OG
you know what I mean like you you've
you've seen this game from a lot of
different areas with me I'm more like if
it's really like if you if it's really
like some type of pressure you you have
to like address me like for real or you
have to like address me in real life
like
people see me outside I'm outside
everywhere I'm everywhere I'm at every
Festival I'm at every show so I don't
really feel that energy from anybody
like you know and I don't really give
that energy like I don't have you don't
you give a number positive energy yeah
like I'm so confident and so happy
with what I'm doing that I don't have
really the time to like nitpick girls
for no reason right you know but um yeah
like I'm a positive person for the most
part everybody that knows me knows I
just like to have a good time and spread
love is Russ on the album
not not right now but I'm trying to find
a song for him we were speaking about
that the other day I'm trying to find
like the perfect song Because I Love
Russ he's like one of the most
knowledgeable and talented people and
he's like a like he's like really tell
he I think he yesterday he was teasing
he's gonna put out like a 70s rock song
and I was like bro I bet it's gonna be
fire because he can do everything
he's a beast for sure you've done some
huge festivals like I feel like you've
done them all at this point but like
what was the one Festival you did where
you just looked at the crowd you were
like [__] this is [__] crazy the
biggest one ever yeah or just like or
maybe a nervous moment or just like a
like something that just sticks out the
biggest uh out to this day the biggest
Festival I've ever done was the Telethon
and Chile with J Balvin wow it was 75
000 people it was so many people that I
couldn't even see
like physical people all I could see was
little dots like little heads little
flashes of Lights crazy but that was the
most I've ever seen
um most people ever but but I love just
like Festival crowds because people that
go to festivals like they're going there
yes yeah so that's my favorite my
favorite energy because there's like and
then you go to a nightclub and it's like
there's people in there just like
they're holding their bottles standing
in the [__] booths and they're just
like looking at you like don't get me
wrong I love nightclubs too no no
they're great like I turn the nightclubs
up I just open a nightclub so yes
I come up in yeah we can book you with
Scottsdale I love Arizona too yeah it
gets wild in Scottsdale it does it does
get wild you don't know it gets wild so
you go there and see it for yourself
this is true this is true for you uh
what about going out on tour for your
fans like going and kind of just
touching your direct fan base with a
tour is that something that's coming
with this album yes yes I'm so glad you
asked that because I've never been on my
own tour I didn't say I feel like it
hasn't happened because I'm sure because
of the pandemic never and I'm such like
an like he's like an older OG artist I'm
not I have gone on my own tour but I've
always been on tour with like huge acts
so I feel like it takes up when you go
on tour it takes up months yeah so like
you'll go on tour and you get off tour
you start recording you go on tour again
um and I think that that's just helps me
anyways because when it comes time that
I go on tour there's gonna be like so
many more people for me to see and it's
like they're there for you yeah I can't
wait to see what my tour looks like like
with my fans singing album Cuts you got
the merch booming you know what I'm
saying I'm excited for that so album
coming soon really soon very soon very
very soon yeah I don't like to talk
about it I like to be about it you know
so one day we'll just be like oh the B
album's coming out in two weeks yeah
uh the new record is crazy with
Timberland thank you
um
is there a new single coming yeah
um you know me it's always a new single
coming actually now I've been way more
consistent because like I've been
learning to find that balance like when
you doing so many shows I feel like this
is like new territory for me like I've
the past two years I've been the busiest
I've ever been in my life so I've been
trying to balance like you know
new shows new music seeing family having
a social life all those things is so
hard to do I wonder like when because
I've I've seen artists who will do all
these festivals right and like
they're not doing the the shows we just
talked about like when you do your own
tour does that ever affect the way you
create like have you ever like been like
damn I gotta make a [__] Festival
record because I see a lot of guys doing
that [__] like and sometimes it can it
can kind of work out in the negative
because I think when you try to do stuff
on purpose sometimes it comes across
that way
um yeah you know well I do so many
festivals and so many like just like
like just
shows with high energy so a lot of my
records when I go to the studio are high
energy records because I'm always
picturing myself performing records on
stage but I do have those album Cuts
Like motionless where it's like wait on
16 that's like way more vulnerable where
like I try to you know
talk my [__] but still
still give a Vibe you know
um for me it's like I like to get into
so many different beats like whatever
the beat calls for is what I'm gonna
give
what is uh bia's go-to show to binge
watch right now
it is summertime if you're dealing with
elect erectile dysfunction Ed if you
will maybe you got stress at work maybe
you're tired of looking at the same
chick maybe you just need a little pep
in your step
um you need to get on that blue too man
you don't need to do anything but it'd
be nice to have the option to so go to
bluetooth.com right now
use the promo code bootleg and get the
first month supply of Bluetooth for free
what is Bluetooth
well Bluetooth is a chewable gets
delivered to your door in a discrete
package no doctor's appointments no
doctor's visits
and uh it has the same active ingredient
as Viagra
and Cialis
so we're talking about getting your dick
hard here in case that went over your
head you know it won't go over your head
once you take it I promise you that all
right Bluetooth also is uh incredible
because not only does it come in the
blue chewable flavor with the same
active ingredient as vibrancy house but
it also has a mint chewable flavor which
is the same active ingredient as Levitra
all right all this if you're questioning
I don't know I don't want to spend no
money on does this [__] work look yes it
works and you don't have to spend money
if you use the promo code bootleg at
bluetooth.com because it's going to get
delivered right to your house they're
going to give you a month's supply for
free you just got to pay five dollars
shipping that's it the bluetooth's come
into your house no awkward doctor's
appointments
no awkward doctor's visits it's all
online
bluetooth.com Thank Me Later what's up
guys hey um if you are watching this and
it's April 20th 4 20.
I'm going to be hanging out at hard Dean
today
that's right put the flyer up Lorac
I'll be at hardean um hanging out all
day today uh the craziest most just
luxurious illest dispensary in the world
located right in Los Vegas Nevada now
Hardy in Las Vegas they are our family
they'd sponsor the podcast I love those
guys dearly and when I say that it is
the best place I've ever walked into to
buy premium cannabis I'm not lying best
customer service
best bud tenders best bud
to put in your King Palm
and uh just overall man just a great
experience um so uh what y'all need to
do is go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas follow them on the
gram
we got a lot of dope stuff in the works
they actually just opened a a fire
podcast studio so we're gonna be doing a
lot of content in Vegas
live from Hardin they also just dropped
a [__] tennis shoe with Fila they got
dope fly gear
um man premium cannabis the best
selection
culture
sniff you walk in that man listen they
got I'm not even lying to y'all Harding
has their own signature scent and it
smells good I keep a bottle of it in my
car literally maybe twice a day I spray
get that hard eating whiff smells
amazing so look make sure you go to
hardine uh if you're in Vegas get in
that Uber get in that cab as soon as you
touch down say take me to hardine the
taxi drivers the Ubi drivers they know
exactly where it is because it's the
hottest spot in Vegas they go take you
straight there you're gonna tell them I
sent you they're going to get you
situated real nicely all right Harding
underscore Las Vegas go show them some
love go to hardinglasvegas.com gotta
give a shout out to our oh geez my dogs
had Odd Socks baby they've been [__]
with us from day one
um and they've been dropping so many
crazy dope new like socks you know first
of all can we talk about Beavis and
Butthead they just dropped the Beavis
and Butt-head socks and draws let's take
a check just a nice little peek at the
Beavis and Butt-head draw skis bruh
oh
come on man
they also just dropped Coca-Cola we got
Scarface we got Reese's we got the big
[__] Lebowski so many dope socks the
most comfortable socks in the world the
most comfortable underwear in the world
and check this out right now you can get
20 off that's 20 off at checkout
at oddsoxofficial.com using the promo
code bootleg so go right now
oddsoxofficial.com my first uh
suggestion would be get you a pair or a
pack of the Odd Socks Basics the black
and the whites those are my go-to's and
then you gotta [__] with some of these
Big Lebowski socks and they just got
Coca-Cola
they got the Scarface boys like what are
we talking about man what are you
waiting on they are the most comfortable
socks in the world
um so if you're not wearing Odd Socks
you're just cheating yourself you know
what I mean you're really cheating
yourself
they got a [__] South Park
come on bruh what are we talking about
go to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg save 20 off at
checkout on the most comfortable socks
in the world or don't and keep torturing
yourself with those shitty socks you're
wearing right now
be a damn shame anyway let's go back to
the interview
like what are you watching on TV right
now I'm not watching as much but I love
um I love love Godfather Harlem shout
out to Forest Whitaker yes
shout out to Swiss I'm yet to see the
show I don't have I don't know what
platform it's on but whatever it is I'm
not subscribed so
I think it's like on epics or something
right I don't know I think I don't know
I have everything Netflix Prime and Hulu
but why I love it is because it's like I
I usually watch like documentary stuff
like informative things I like to learn
I love Vice by the way I heard yeah
shout out to vice vice is a great name
back in the day though Vice would just
be ridiculous really like I did heroin
for 30 days straight to see what happens
well you probably became an opiate
addict yeah okay so I like mice so
I drink nothing but beer for a month
yeah I had McDonald's yeah lots of Vice
yeah so Vice if I'm not watching Vice
like I like Godfather Harlem because
it's like a show like almost like you
know how power is like a show and it's
like action and there's stuff's going
down it's like that but it's real like a
lot of the stuff that's going on in the
show you like wow this is really this
happened yeah I heard like it kind of
dives into like some of the Malcolm X
[__] it goes into like real yeah I heard
it's great so you kind of see like why
things are the way they are but it makes
it into a show you ever watch
Yellowstone no but I heard that was so
good it is good I'm gonna watch that one
it is a good show when I find uh some
Netflix it's definitely it's on Netflix
no it's like on Paramount Plus Peacock I
don't know peacock Kevin Costner's
a snowfall
oh don't ask me that you didn't watch it
I watched bits and pieces of softball
I've never watched it straight what
about breaking bad yes I did you
finished it all not the whole thing
with the wire no
but you like Power yes I love power you
see you gotta Watch The Wire the wire is
like I love power
I've seen that like I watched the first
two I like BMF too bmf's good yeah shout
out to uh little meech you I mean would
you uh for you like uh if you could
if you could
ever get into like acting being an
actress like would you ever try to do
that yeah is that I mean I feel like you
you should do it
um I feel like I had to be a role that
that
kind of like me
so it doesn't feel like I'm acting
because when I go on like acting
auditions you've done that yeah oh I'm
so bad well I'm not so bad but I mean
maybe I just need some practice you
gotta go to a coach but I gotta go I
gotta get the roles that are like good
for me yeah you know you want to get
typecasted at first
like I don't want to go and do a role
that's like oh what is she she's trying
to be that role listen when Ice Cube
first started acting they just casted
him as Ice Cube that's what I need I
need a casting Ice Cube is in boys in
the hood just playing himself really and
you could just you know play yourself
see if Little Dicky will put you an
episode of Dave next season that's a
good idea as Bia
see see what you can do that have you
ever watched Dave
Little Dicky
Dave's good have you seen it
it's really funny you don't watch a lot
of TV except Godfather of Harlem I only
watched that like power informative
stuff what about what about movies
what's your like favorite movie ever
give me like two or three because I'm
sure there's a few coming here oh
no I'm so bad with movies you don't
watch movies no Jesus
I'm like a creative you're just making
making smashes and cooking a lot uh I'm
like closing and like doing nails and
like you do your own Nails yeah like
hanging out with my friends you did this
yourself so I did a few of them this
this um talented girl did the other ones
can we see the nails just show them show
the nails no you gotta hold on so what
happened was she made me this set
originally because lately I've been a
little too busy to do my nails and I
broke like three of them so I had to
redo them on my own wow yeah so have you
always done your own nails like is that
something like a skill you picked up I
picked it up in the pandemic
yep I'm a beauty uh Beauty Guru now so
you could cook you could do your own
Nails I could cook I have a makeup line
makeup line at where can people is that
available currently yes it's available
at beautyforcertain.com
beautyforcertain.com I'll get you one is
kind of clear so nobody will tell that
you're wearing gloss it'll just I give
it to my wife my wife's a huge fan of
yours by the way oh really oh she's all
[__] she's just working out and your
shit's just [__]
look at the color
Beauty for certain isn't it cute I like
that and it fits in literally everything
I like that check you out your
entrepreneur getting it in anything else
you got cooking you're gonna start a
restaurant
um maybe a nail salon or something I
love nails do you still are you still
based in uh Massachusetts or are you
just L.A okay I've been in L.A for a
while you don't miss a missed the shitty
weather and the
you know angry looking white folks
everywhere my family but that's about
that's the my the
most I miss
how you feel about your Celtics I love
the Celtics
go Celtics you gotta get Jason Tatum in
a music video yeah or Jalen Brown
or Mark you're smart or Marcus Smart
I'll I would get all three of them in a
music video get all three all three you
really
it's a good video yeah I like it you
feel good about the Celtics here like do
we think they're gonna come back James
Harden just gave him you know game 45
it was rough it's like how could you
doubt them look at that look at what
they do they come through so it's like
just just relax
just relax because Tatum your favorite
Celtic
Island it's probably one of my favorite
Celtics is really good Karen Brown is
amazing I heard his dad is like making
the Stein's bodyguard or some [__]
oh I don't know that I think that's true
I think Jay I think I think his dad's
making this Italian's bodyguard we
wouldn't know that you know what's crazy
like I'm gonna ask him that because I
don't know how I wouldn't know that like
be like hey does your dad do something
with making the staff are you sure it's
him I'm pretty I'm like a hundred I'm
like 99.9 sure his dad is somehow
Yes actually I'm sure I'm 100 sure if if
you know that and we don't know that and
we actually like are friends with Jane
doesn't want that like out there you
know then oh yeah that's that's I never
heard that one before I think it's I
think I could be totally wrong
Hey listen I'm gonna ask he might have
got maybe you gotta let go
I don't know well listen new album
coming soon
with good purpose obviously
new album coming very soon
um new single with uh Timberland out he
made that beat right yes Timberland and
um Skip and little rich like they all
cooked up and they did their like
producationally I can do anything this
[__] made a drill beat like he
could do he does country does Justin
Timberlake yeah that's why I was so
excited too that was his idea to do to
do a drone fire yeah he was like let's
flip this and let's do it did he started
off with like a Beat Box because I heard
sometimes he'd be in the studio just you
know I mean like he's always I feel like
the whole time he was beatboxing like
it's like natural for him it's amazing
yeah so talented shout out to Timberland
shout out to You album coming soon go
buy some makeup and you're gonna go buy
some makeup uh Tour on the way
um and yeah Bia appreciate you thank you
so much boom